c'est une véritable psychose qui est en
train de naître du côté de certains
membres du personnel hospitalier au
sujet du vaccin astrazeneca contre la
copie de 19 en cause des effets
secondaires indésirables qui serait très
puissant chez de nombreuses personnes
vaccinées au chu de brest 25 % du
personnel médical ayant reçu une
injection du vaccin astrazeneca a été
contraint de se mettre en arrêt de
travail suite à l'état grippal violence
dans lequel cette injection les a
plongés j'étais couché toute la journée
d'hier
j'étais très contente d'avoir été
vacciné et ses pages sur un petit peu de
regrets comme certains médecins refusent
tout bonnement de se faire vacciner par
ce produit
le professeur alain fischer a indiqué
qu'il prenait très au sérieux cette
alerte et que les effets secondaires du
vaccin allait être étudié minutieusement
l'avantagent du prize heures c'est que
l'immunité et plus rapide
le rappelle se faisant au bout de trois
semaines alors les médecins ont-ils
raison de se poser au vaccin astrazeneca
alors les médecins ont-ils raison de
s'opposer au pacs un astrazeneca merci
alors j'aimerais qu'on ait déjà la vie
de vous tous que vous vous avez tous un
avis vous avez tous et tout documenter
après on aura bien sûr la vie de jimmy
dreux med neuf docteur et du côté de
commissaires roddick qui tirent et nous
faire si je suis à la merci beaucoup
oui pour moi cela honteux qu'on autorise
un vaccin sur lequel viarouge une alors
juste les chéris c'est quelqu'un de
sérieux même si là il ya quand même un
rideau de voyons sur lui normalement il
ya marqué voyance est injuste après il
est innée sérieux chez quelqu'un pour
moi c'est honteux qu'on autorise un
versant un vaccin sur lequel il ya
autant de doutes on n'est pas des rats
de laboratoire on est des humains non
pour moi il faut l'interdire tout de
suite ce vaccin et c'est très bien de
vouloir aller vite c'est très bien de
vouloir répondre aux demandes des
français et du monde entier sur le la
demande de vaccins mais pour moi
autorisé ce vaccin vu le nombre
d'articles qu'on lit avec des rumeurs
sur des effets secondaires oui il faut
l'intérieur justement alors justement
justement aller à béton mouche et les
rhumes art et honneur allez c'est parti
mais je ne suis ni médecin ni p2 mais je
connais je n'y connais rien je veux dire
que c'est beaucoup dans les cliniques
voilà s'est arrêté avec jal si c'était à
refaire la bouche la poitrine
mais c'est plus castaldi et si beaucoup
de pays ont autorisé le vaccin j'ai
envie de leur faire confiance c'est
relayé dans des médias c'est leur cas il
ya eu 7 6 7 millions personnes vaccinées
le circuit secondaire sont noyés 200
personnes qui auraient un effet
secondaire honnêtement c'est encore que
tu n'es pas qualifié et moi non plus
d'ailleurs
pour en parler on a droit d'un doigt et
non mais tu peux tu inquiété pour toi tu
étais en baie de liens qu'il faut
interdire ce vaccin ni toi ni moi ni
personne ici un apparat par jimmy peut
donner une réponse et et vous bien sûr
que vous êtes le chef ou alors vous je
vous ferai vacciner contre le mauvais
goût moi je trouve qu'on a raison les
médecins qui auraient trop près d'elle
pédaler il avait des informations que
nous menons nous nous ne disposons pas
mais la prudence et 10 rebonds mais
soyons attentiste parce qu'on n'est pas
sûr de l'effet de la positivité de ce
vaccin va d'effets positifs de ce vaccin
je trouve ça normal ça veut pas dire
qu'on ne fait pas confiance ça veut dire
qu'on a raison d'être prudent c'est tout
un pas dans le coin mais c'est pas très
malin
tellement c'est toujours pareil parce
qu'au départ on est parti sur la rn
message est alors attention la rn
message et c'est super dangereux c'est
tout nouveau il va y avoir une tête de
cheval m'a poussé puis 4
donc c'était un délire et puis après
tout le monde roulait à l'air l arn
messagers c'était génial
là c'est la stran et cas le made in
china alors là nouveau suspicion alors
raul lui dit que s'il y en a un valable
celle astrazeneca donc encore une fois
il ya mis la vie enfin moi je pense
qu'il faut faire un témoin j'aurais
demandé à jimmy dimmitt le million
d'âmes on fera parler les productrices
voulais rester mais je pense que les
révolutionnaires c'est bon signe
il suffit de regarder les chiffres dans
les hôpitaux le personnel soignant a été
vaccinée avec l'astra zeneca 25 %
d'arrêts de travail c'est monstrueux à
brest à morlaix à périgueux ils ont
failli fermer arrêter la vaccination
le personnel est malade symptômes de la
grippe donc ce vaccin il est dangereux
sur raison de s'opposer
il faut arrêter la vaccination est
tolérée tous les ans tous les vaccins
ont des effets secondaires donc tous les
vaccins ce moment là il faudrait tout
c'est d'arrêter parce que tu si tu te la
cne de la grippe tu peux aussi avoir de
la fièvre des maux de tête des céphalées
et c'est donc dans ces cas-là on arrête
tout en vain
vous et moi avec l'engagement des
céphalées non mais si tu me donnes moi
c'est la cacophonie
cela fait un moment qu'on est français
on a dit ils ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner puis tout d'un coup la wii se
sont rendus compte que abba dont ils
veulent se faire vacciner maintenant
qu'on va se faire vacciner
une déambulation ya le bon vin 10 ans il
ya le mauvais vaccin on sait pas trop où
il ya le vaccin il va peut-être arriver
mais on sait pas ce qu on attend d un
moment il ya un vaccin
on nous dit que ça fonctionne on le
prend points alors nicolas pernikoff
plusieurs vaccins et le breezer il ya
beaucoup moins d'effets secondaires ne
dément totalement
je comprends totalement les médecins de
sont inquiétés en plus ce que dis-je il
ya quand même une personne sur quatre
qui a eu des effets secondaires ce qui
n'est pas le cas avec le kaiser
donc c'est normal enfin je serai à leur
place moi je me poserai exactement la
même question
tiffany et puis visiblement c'est le
signe d'une bonne immunité voulait avoir
des symptômes après avoir fait un c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure j'ai
khalid allié avec les effets secondaires
nouvelle ya vu un thé un pays de l'union
européenne il n'y a pas eu ce genre de
symptômes et surtout je me demande ils
ont dit que maintenant les médecins
généralistes d'ici une dizaine de jours
ils allaient pouvoir justement faire ce
vaccin dans leur cabinet donc ils
veulent pas le faire mais par contre ils
vont le faire à leurs patients alors on
me dit knox voilà dans un hôpital de
bordeaux la consigne est claire
alors je suis passé à prendre à des avec
lui bien sûr au conditionnel mais il ya
des gens qui disent que interdiction de
vacciner tout un service avec la
stratégie ou de services j leur espace
cas des services où il ya tellement
d'arrêt de travail
ils se disent si on continue à vacciner
c'est tout le service qui doit fermer
et donc ce sont les malades qui sont en
danger parole du gouvernement
bien sûr le porte parole de la voilà non
non on sait très bien on sait très bien
qu'on doit à vacciner les mots les
soignants de moins de 50 ans en fait
pourquoi parce que les personnes âgées
développent moins rapidement un jimmy
ils développent moins rapidement si si
il n'y a pas d'effets secondaires pour
les personnes âgées
mais les imiter mais limité on parle d'
immunité
on parle mais vous comprenez ce que je
dire
les personnes âgées développent moins
fser un ca conseil n'est pas vide chez
la vie les personnes âgées développent
moins d'effets secondaires au vaccin
c'est pour ça que le rapport effet la
question c'est oui c'est pour ça qu'on a
préféré donner cette astra zeneca aux
soignants de moins de 50 ans à la
question un pari mais raison pas non
mais non mais il savait un truc il
fallait que je dise ouais ça va quitter
toujours à côté de la plaque johnny
hallyday va nous parler des di michele
ces voix là c'est la règle on le connaît
voilà il est là depuis des années il a
fait carrière sur ça on va pas les
boutons c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que
je suis presque mal à l'aise du coup de
porter le débat parce que je me rends
compte que c'est très confus c'est
l'impression à bernard montiel
c'est vrai que peut-être que je jouais
genre donné un mauvais message la
vaccination ça sauve des vies et c'est
ce qui nous permettra de sortir de la
crise dit aucun doute le vaccin
astrazeneca il est efficace sur le les
coronavirus circulant il est aussi
efficace sur le variant angles est donc
c'est une bonne nouvelle donc si votre
médecin vous propose de vous faire
vacciner avec ce vaccin je vous
recommande d'accepter faire confiance à
votre médecin de ville d'autant plus que
à partir de cette semaine ou la semaine
prochaine en médecine de ville
nous aurons la presby la possibilité
nous médecins généralistes d'avoir dix
doses pour vacciner la population donc
le vaccin axes tracés astrazeneca pardon
il faut l'accepter si votre médecin vous
le propose en revanche la question c'est
celle des soignants on sait que le
vaccin arn files heures et moderna est
extrêmement efficace sur le court d'un
virus classique sur le variant anglais
mais aussi sur les variantes qui nous
inquiète en ce moment et qui inquiète le
gouvernement
le variant sud africain et brésilien est
la question que j'aimerais vous poser au
début tu es aussi confrères qui en face
de moi alors ça c'est mon frère aussi
hot c'est exactement les médecins et ça
les commissaires borowicz gt
des pinces à linge ce vaccin qu'on
propose aux soignants sa légitime quand
vous pouvez nous dire quelle efficacité
at-il d'après les dernières études sur
le variant sud africain et pourquoi est
ce qu'on propose ce vaccin là aux
soignants et pas le faiseur la rn à qui
on a proposé au tout début de vacciner
les soignants c'est une bonne question
d'efficacité et pourquoi ce qu'on
propose celui là désormais alors moi je
veux juste avant je vais dire sur deux
trois trucs qui ont été de lit parce que
je crois qu'il est on en parlait tout à
l'heure il faut pas faire l'amalgamé
entre un problème d'efficacité du vaccin
et les effets secondaires
il ya des effets secondaires qui sont
effectivement plus fréquents sur le
astrazeneca qui sont des effets
secondaires assez classique c'est-à-dire
de la fièvre des douleurs musculaires
etc qui disparaissent autour de 24 48
heures sur ce problème là effectivement
il est tout à fait intéressant d'étaler
les vaccinations dans la population
soignante pour éviter d'avoir des arrêts
de travail
ça c'est un fait s'agissant de
l'efficacité du vaccin
nous avons un bac 5 et efficace à
environ 70% s'agissant du astrazeneca
je rappelle que l' oms pour
l'organisation mondiale de la santé pour
valider le vaccin disait il faut qu'il y
ait plus de 50%
je rappelle également que le vaccin
contre la grippe c'est entre 40 et 60 et
on le fait régulièrement sans aucun
d'eux propres sans aucun problème le
kaiser et de modern art on les utilise
sur des personnes de plus de 65 ans
parce que nous n'avons pas de preuve
d'efficacité de ce vaccin pour les gens
de plus de 75 ans 65 ans donc là
strazeele et cas on utilise pour les
moins de 65 ans et en particulier sur
les personnels soignants parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya une efficacité dessus qui
dira la raison mais à combien la roma me
tiens mais messi parce que là n'est pas
admise en sciences comptables mais on
sud africain et brésilien quelle est
l'efficacité d'astrazeneca dessus
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de papiers sur
alors il ya quelques études qui ont
lancé ce n'est ses études il ya quelques
temps la culture lancé sur le sud
africain sur le vaillant sud africain il
y aurait moins d'efficacité de la
stramilano qu'amiens parce qu'il ya
moins et moins la rn qui passe à 95 avec
astral le sud africain ils passent pas à
la base on a 95 % avec le freezer le
moderna et donc on va diminuer un petit
peu mais on va être largement au-dessus
des 50%
l'inquiétude des parents sur l'astra
zeneca vous voulez pas dire le chiffre
je crois que les études montrent que le
vaccin
astrazeneca à l'heure actuelle et
peut-être que ça avait évolué au fur et
à mesure
temps va passer sur le variant sud
africains brésiliens marche à 22% alors
justement la main et locales il a été
arrêté en entre 20 et 30 exactement
entre 20 et 30 sauf que en dessous de 50
en dehors de la grippe ça ne peut pas
accepter cette vaccination est là le
problème
et c'est qu'on n'a pas expliqué on
explique aux gens qu'on va se vacciner
avec astrazeneca
mais c'est juste qu'il faut dire que
parce qu'on n'a pas assez de modern art
et pfizer sujet parce qu'ils sont encore
une stratégie de pénurie et on propose
de soignants le parisien le moins
efficace alors que c'est eux qui sont au
quotidien au charbon en première ligne
qui ont souvent payé un lourd tribut
liés aux coronavirus et au bout d'un an
on ne dit vaccinez vous avec ça c'est
pas audible et au nahd monsieur vaccin
monsieur le professeur alain fischer est
éminemment et éminent scientifique qui
dit qu'en moselle
là où le variant sud africain est
présent il ne faut plus vacciner les
soignants non avec astrazeneca donc ça
veut dire que non c'est très bien ce qui
se passe on n'a pas de stratégie de pour
limiter la propagation du bios et qu'est
ce qui va se passer
pour bien comprendre la différence entre
le variant angles est et sud africain le
variant angles est il arrivé dans un
contexte particulier en angleterre où il
a cherché à être plus contagieux à se
transmettre plus facilement au travers
des gens alors que le variant sud
africain et brésilien arrivé dans une
dans un contexte on avait de l'immunité
collective les gens sont tous tombés
malades levé le virus à essayer de
survivre et l'a rendu les gens malades
donc au fur et à mesure qu'on va
vacciner les gens le variant sud
africain va prendre plus de proportion
les soignants qui sont en première ligne
non aux urgences en médecine de ville
vont être confrontés à ce virus
et comme ils ont eu astrazeneca c'est ce
qu'on propose ils ne seront pas protégés
non ils vont tomber malade ils vont avec
le virus et trois peut-être qu'ils ont
le ramener à la maison parce qu on
oublie que les soignants ont une famille
peut-être pas forcément vite d'autres
français mais là moi j'aime bien rouler
lentement alors c'est bien moi je veux
bien entendre sa tante de choses mais là
il ya des amalgames là encore c'est à
dire que quand vous me dites on va
ramener à la maison vous le ferez pareil
avec un riser un enfant dort jamais
protégé massif either il prône l emphase
et astrazeneca ne protège pas de la
contamination
alors ça aussi c'est une histoire mais
pour l'instant le lac sans faillir à la
tradition du bio du milieu appuyez-vous
sur les dernières données de la science
et les dernières données de la science
oui nous explique que le modern art et
phaser réduisent la transmission du
virus est certainement astrazeneca et on
a un doute sur un des pasteurs
il ya quinze jours il ya trois semaines
on disait la même chose sur le finder et
moderna c'est à dire bernard
on me dira avec le recul on est en train
de le faire sur la stratégie alors
pourquoi simplement il ya aussi un
problème mais j'entends ce que vous me
dites c'est à dire que ce que vous êtes
en train de me dire et c'est là que ça
me pose un vrai problème face à cause de
problèmes ça pose un premier problème c
est vous l'avez dit en introduction
c'est que ça galvaude un peu le message
sur les vaccins et c'est un petit peu
dommage parce que moi même je
vaccinerait la semaine prochaine des
patients dans mon cabinet vous vous êtes
fait vacciner vous alors à aa
non je sens que je me faire attaquer non
soldés sur votre plateau il n'y a pas
très longtemps mais c'était ce qui se
passe je l'avais annoncé je le ferai
vacciner le lendemain je me suis fait
vacciner lendemain mais il soit savent
que c'est est d'une fadeur pourquoi
parce que pour une fois que d'être gross
avait un avantage
eh bien eh ben oui jamais une
comorbidité donc je me suis fait
vacciner oprisor oui mais là même qu
morbide mais aujourd'hui n'est plus
valable quelqu'un de 50 ans juste jolie
mais c'est là que je ne sais pas audible
nicolas pernikoff à une information pour
vous et après on va aller on va laisser
dire j'ai l'information une grosse
question c'est que l'astra zeneca ont
adoré poser la question plus tôt et
jardins la strada n'est qu'à on connaît
son prix 1,7 officialisé ses 1 euros 78
quand le modern haifa isr soit entre 12
et 15 euros
et quand on sait que israël à payer deux
fois plus cher pour avoir plein de
vaccins et qu'ils ont vacciné 40% des
gens est ce que la question c'est pas
tout simplement que l'astra z'années cas
mais comme on est toujours à l'économie
des vaccins est-ce que c'est pas tout
simplement parce qu'il est un euro 78
très bonne question parce que c'est dix
fois moins cher que les autres
oui la question des pas du tout dans
s'étendre là je reviens sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
première chose qui m'embête c'est est
effectivement la marianne deuxième chose
vous l'avez dit c'est c'est un vrai
problème de dos de nombre de doses c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui nous sommes à
nombre de nos ce constant mais c'est
valable partout en europe 1 pas
spécifiquement en france et donc de fait
si vous voulez qu'on fasse accéder les
soignants à un faiseur ou un modern a
une fois de plus je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient vraiment une amélioration
foncièrement importante du résultat vous
allez faire en sorte que les personnes
les plus à risque de complications c'est
à dire les plus de 65 ans ou n'ait pas
accès aux failles zero moderne active
car s'arrête non mais c'est la réalité
c'est-à-dire que vous créez vous créez
un problème de valeurs entre les
soignants d'un côté et les personnels
qu'ils arrêteront et soit le jeu rapstar
donne franchement c'est dur
internet je rappelle je rappelle que 93
% de la mortalité c'est des gens depuis
65 ans donc inéluctablement à doses de
vaccin constante il est plus important
de donner aux plus fragiles je ne dis
pas que les soignants ne doivent pas
être en premier mais ce ne sont pas les
plus fragiles
donc je pense que c'est en raison ce
sont les plus exposés mais moi je vais
vous rappeler un chiffre les soignants
aujourd'hui et soignants hospitalier ces
2 % du nombre d'infectés dans le nombre
d'infectés globale en france
et curieusement ce sont pas spécialement
les gens en réanimation mais les gens
qui travaillent en réanimation qui sont
le plus infecté
parce qu'il ya justement de la
protection et à une surexposition mais
pas forcément une surcontamination
d'accord après il ya un choix et les
salaires je l'entends mais je crois que
c'est 4 il faut faire attention à ne pas
faire il faut faire la différence entre
des gens les plus exposés et les gens
les plus à risque d'avoir des
complications
or aujourd'hui la france à prioriser ces
gens là et moi j'en suis fier pour
répondre à la question juste avant des
années petit cola pernikoff avec ce
france télévisions c'est là qu'il fait
la pluie et le beau temps sur tous les
prime times c'était donc lui non juste
juste une chose
d'abord ce n'est pas une question de
prix parce que on a on a pré réserver
les vaccins avant même qu'on ait
déterminé le prix
deuxièmement il ya une petite notion
mois que j'aime faire passer s'agissant
d'israël
on parle du prix effectivement dix ans
et plus cher eux ils ont investi
pourquoi ils l'ont eu mon premier israël
pas pour des raisons de prix parce
qu'ils ont vendu les données de santé
des israéliens à pfizer ça c'est le
grand c'est l'argument ça mais ils ont
quand même pu alors c'est plus été sur
ces files heures a accès aux données de
santé des israéliens accord par contrat
d'accord ce qui en france ne paraît pas
vraiment de ma nature très élégante la
maison quand même payer deux fois plus
cher parce qu'il en a acheté moins
également question n'est pas de savoir
si c'est le prix je veux dire
franchement quand on voit le prix d'une
journée de réanimation on va pas mégoter
sur le dos tout début le gouvernement a
dit qu'il allait se mettre d'accord que
tous les européens les semaines d'accord
ensemble contre les états unis quand
donald trump avait pris la parole en
disant
on va on va dire et on va payer pour
l'avoir avant tout le monde aujourd'hui
le résultat et vous le savez c'est que
ne serait ce que pour la production des
vaccins qui sont attendues en mars avril
mai mais on sait même pas un pour tous
les vaccins donc ça veut dire qu'en
france aujourd'hui on est à sec
il n'y a pas de vaccin en réalité très
peu de vaccins donc vous voyez en avance
sur nous en avons trois semaines de
décalage entre d'un ou de retard
exactement et le reste de l'europe
de quoi vous parlez pas en livraison des
vaccins y va on à 15% la totalité vaccin
européen ces pros au prorata du nombre
d'habitants
par contre pourquoi on a vacciné sur un
délai différent c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas fait du open bar on vaccine tout le
monde on a vacciné les plus à risque
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est à soi
on a une moyenne d'âge de 74 ans de gens
vaccinés on est à 37 en espagne parce
qu'ils ont accédé tout le monde mais une
fois de plus ça rejoint ce que je disais
il vaut mieux vacciner les gens les plus
fragiles encore justement la stratégie
elle est bonne pour l'instant estime que
si vous voulez on va avoir en mars à
partir de mars
on va pouvoir voir c'est demain mars
c'est très bientôt elle va pouvoir
installer je vous lis a plus de saison
ça arrive à le prendre à la tronche et
ah oui non non il faut avoir une
décorrélation entre un taux d'incidence
qui pourrait augmenter mais de manière
parallèle n'aura pas une augmentation du
taux d'hospitalisation
lorsqu'on aura max idées les plus
fragiles celles qu'on leur confie nez ou
pas c'est pas notre but je pense que là
là moi j'entends de plus en plus de gens
qui lisent
a priori on va par confiner du tout à
ces panneaux de but et effectivement on
espère justement n'ayant vacciner les
plus fragiles qu'on évitera ce jardin a
fait ça serait une belle victoire pour
bon vin ça serait surtout une belle
victoire pour l'économie française et
pour la société parce que c'était pas
des vrais sujets mais moi j'y crois oui
bien sûr j'y crois parce qu'aujourd'hui
on à moi je dans mon département j'ai
encore regardé les chiffres c'est aussi
d'anciens bons et c'est à dire contre
est un des seuls pays
oui à ne pas avoir confiné à s'en sortir
oui donc on est des génies je ne dis pas
qu'on ait des génies mais il dit en tout
cas pour l'instant ça marche et je pense
qu'on pourrait on a bien travaillé
ensemble passant même si la marche moyen
quand même un énorme et ça marche
on n'a eu quasiment 600 morts ce soir
encore du courant à 2 600 morts c'est
bien là dessus a encore mené on est
toujours sur le plateau comme chaque
automne ou à 18 heures le rideau est
fermé on n'a aucun divertissement aucune
perspective
et à ce rythme là on va atteindre lors
je me réjouis d'être masqué des
perspectives d'avoir à ouvrir les geôles
sert à peu dans une expérimentation 20
min comme il avait mis un peu en
concurrence le fait que si jamais un
tour d'internet
mais si c'est ici mais c'est ma part je
sais pas où l'éthique
d'accord je vous renvoyer la sepa
politique c'est étiez quoi sur quoi
pascal rosales et éthiques
quand vous avez dit si on vaccine les
soignants avec le faiseur on va manquer
de doses pour les personnes fragile
c'est la rue danton ans que nous nous
allons prendre les vaccins des fragiles
évidemment que j'ai pensé vous avez reçu
files heures et je vous ai pas reprocher
de prendre le vaccin était pour moi qui
ai dit vous mettez en concurrençant lire
j'aime lire ce sens donc c'est très bien
parce que vous vous êtes en vacances est
très bas ne pas soigner et ne pas
protéger
non mais j'imagine ça très malhonnête et
vous été vaccinées aufhaeuser machin
quand je pense que les soignants voit
jamais volé en quelques accidents fire
pour les avec comorbidités voilà je
trouve que vous avez pu constater j'ai
quelques kilos en trop je fais rien
mais ça fait gonfler la bourse non mais
honnêtement voilà voilà aussi un moment
donné à un moment donné je me suis fait
vacciner dans un ehpad celui de ma
content de ma commune à montbrison dans
la loire
pourquoi j'ai fait ça aussi parce que je
vous rappelle qu'à ce moment là c'était
les premières vaccinations et que
personne ne voulait se faire vacciner
personne à l'époque on disait ouais mais
c'est une catastrophe aérienne message
et c'est nul
alors maintenant on est en train de nous
dit à brian message et c'est vachement
il ya eu un mieux que la stratégie cas
voilà il ya un moment d vous-même
d'ailleurs vous disiez dans un tweet qui
a pas très longtemps c'est c'est
efficace la bière il ya donc allez vous
faire vacciner à l'astral astrazeneca ou
pas non non je tendrais qui est des
doses et je continuerai d'être vigilants
tant qu'on aura merck à 64 ans elle
l'aura astrazeneca et jeu-là vaccinerait
dès que possible pour la protéger le
débat porte sur les soignants unis grand
public sur la population générale mais
moi en tant que soignant et en et je
suis exposé au virus tous les jours et
que je vais finir il a rencontré le
vario africain j'attendrai d'avoir un
vaccin suffisamment efficace sur ces
variants sur le nom de qu'astrazeneca et
efficace sur le variant sud africain et
brésilien gérer le faire en revanche
population générale où ils faites vous
vacciner je veux donner un seul chiffre
l'angleterre 15 millions de personnes
vaccinées ils ont simplement réussi
l'essentiel d'un bien sûr des médias oui
maison le variant d'un anglais chez eux
n'aiment pas de verio brésilien qui est
pour l'instant de majorité hervé paillet
l'enjeu est là on s'est quand même
alors on va voir non mais on n'est pas
on n'est pas non mais attendez une fois
de plus on a soumis ribot placement des
médailles aux jo
on est devant la chine mais non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est temps on n'a
jamais dit qu'on était là pour arriver
au top ten simplement ce qui nous a pour
quoi mars qui nous attend ce qui est
important c'est surtout qu'avec les
doses dont on dispose on a vacciné les
gens les plus fragiles je me répète
c'est quand même aujourd'hui la priorité
c'est voilà aujourd'hui on a vacciné on
est à 70 % des vaccinations dans les
ehpad auraient regardé 75 pression des
gens disent oui les médecins qu'ils
raison de s'opposer au vaccin
astrazeneca ce vaccin qui pose question